And not only was it Super Bowl fever,
but over in Hollywood
there was the SAG Award announcements.
Yeah, and you remember last week
if you watched the show,
we were in mourning.
Literally a black vail when Bridgerton was snobbed,
it was a terrible day for us.
Well, guess what,
chins up everybody
because at the SAG Awards
Bridgerton nominated for best ensemble
which is their version of that show.
And Rege-Jean Page was nominated for best actor.
Yes.
(applause)
I remember Phoebe Dynevor and Rege-Jean Page
came and visited us
at the news desk.
Yeah.
So we're just so happy for them
and the Emmys is next and you know.
Thank you.
I feel like the SAGS righted the wrong that the Globes did.
The world is back to normal,
everybody calm down.
I agree.
You've got Super Bowl (indistinct).
Yes.
SAG Awards for Hollywood fans and pop culture.
And then there is more exciting news
and this for me might be the most meaningful of them all.
Time Magazine just released their new cover
featuring poet laureate Amanda Gorman.
(applause)
Superstar.
I am a little bit shaky right now
about how much I love her
and the Super Bowl was also smart enough
to have her do a reading
from the inauguration
to the Super Bowl
to Time Magazine,
I also feel like a true renaissance is going to happen
all due to her Poetry, expression,
words.
Everything is going to version
because of this one young woman
who is changing the game single handedly,
and yet she's going to have
the greatest effect on us all.
And the Time Magazine is the Black Renaissance double issue.
She's interviewed by Michelle Obama
but I'm like,
from inauguration to the Super Bowl
to Time Magazine,
Amanda Gorman she talks about struggling with speech issues,
something that she has in common with President Biden
and another poet Maya Angelou
who people have said she is an embodiment of.
She studied to become a better writer
and Amanda is such a rockstar and a bright light.
Go get this issue.
Yeah. It's pretty incredible.
The hottest person in show business right now
is a poet laureate, right?
Name is Amanda Gorman.
Amazing.
And just having such a moment.
All right, the next story Drew comes to us from New Orleans.
Mardi Gras is coming up just next week,
are you ready?
And even though the parades have been canceled
for the first time in 40 years,
people are still finding a way to celebrate.
You can't keep people down
when they want to celebrate Mardi Gras.
People reports New Orleans residents
are turning their homes into Mardi Gras floats.
Yeah, check this out.
We've got pictures.
These were done by artists
and just everyday people who wouldn't be
brought down by the pandemic.
They are adapting to the year
and keeping this incredibly rich tradition alive.
I love this.
I've never been in Mardi Gras.
I've been in New Orleans.
But I'd love to go one day.
I'm just afraid people would try to give me beads
to keep my top on.
(laughter)
But have you ever been?
I did.
I did go to Mardi Gras.
And?
Oh, it was so much fun.
But don't you love that these people just said, "Yeah,
"we can't have a parade.
"we can't do what we normally do."
And these are parade people down there.
That they just said, "We're going to do it our way."
I just love the look of the homes too.
They saved Mardi Gras.
They did.
Okay.
And next step is a story of a man who saved something else
that's very precious.
This story really, really, really speaks to me Ross.
So the New York Post reports that this
garbage truck driver in Ohio,
well, he saw something moving in the garage.
He saw a backpack actually shape shifting,
and he went and he picked it up
and he unzipped it
and inside was a abandoned puppy.
Oh my gosh!
You're trying to kill me Drew.
I know.
Yeah.
Oh my God, look.
He took her to the vet,
she got treated,
and ultimately he said, "You know what,
"I think we found each other
"and I'm going to adopt her."
There is a reason that man saw that bag move
and this is one of those stories that
if you're having a bad day,
and a story like this pops up on your news feed,
it's for a reason too
because it makes you remember
there's so much goodness in the world.
I found out about it an it just
overtook my whole day.
It just gave me that hope.
The look in both of their eyes,
I really took this one to heart.
I have to say thank you.
I read it in one of those moments
when I needed a good story and there it was.
Me too.
It was exactly right Rossy.
And well, we hope it was a good story for you.
Another thing that makes people feel real good,
a good old-fashioned rom-com.
Oh.
Yeah, give me a puppy and a rom-com honey.
I'm good, all right?
(laughter)
By the way, true.
Yeah, what won't it cure?
Nothing.
Exactly.
And now Apartment Therapy says
a new study crunched the numbers
to find out what was the most watched rom-com
on Valentine's Day.
Now, Drew and I were reading this for the first time.
I said, "I don't want to know what it is."
Me too.
You don't know. Okay, right.
We're going to find out.
Ross and I like to do things fresh.
If we play a game here, we do not know the questions,
let alone the answers.
We like spontaneous reactions.
You can never get it back once you know,
so keep it fresh.
Plus we're really bad liars.
We can't fake it.
Okay, so 2020
and the number one movies for Valentine's Day was...
For reals? The Princess Bride?
Oh, good for everyone.
Good for everyone.
If you haven't seen that,
that's an oldie
but a good movie.
Oh, you have to.
My daughters and I play it all the time.
What about this one?
This one I can understand,
"Pretty Woman".
Which took two years in a row
before the "Princess Bride" one.
"Hello Pretty Woman."
Do you know that was originally called "3000"?
Yes, I do because he paid her $3000.
I love that you know that
because I just found out.
I just found that out.
Yeah, there was a different ending too
and we actually worked with Raja Gosnell
who is the editor of "Pretty Woman"
and the director of "Never Been Kissed".
(Ross gasps)
So yes,
I try to get every piece of information (indistinct).
I'm Googling it later.
It's so cool.
All right.
There's also a map of the most popular
February 14th rom-coms in every single state
and it looks like Washington and California,
where I'm from or where you're from,
they went for "Princess Bride".
But our state where we live now in New York,
they loved "Crazy Rich Asians" in 2020,
which is a great movie too.
I was just going to say I just was watching that
the other night with Olive.
We love that movie so much.
Well, you know...
And I'm looking here too,
you should go to Minnesota next and Hawaii
because "50 First Dates" was their favorite movie.
Wait.
(applause)
It's banned.
It's been number one there for three years in a row.
No.
Oh my gosh!
Well, first of all Hawaii is so great
because that's where we made it.
Yeah.
But Minnesota,
I'm so honored.
I love Minnesota,
that's so cool.
Congrats to you.
Oh my God.
Thank you Minnesota,
thank you Hawaii.
And speaking of Valentine's Day,
if you have a special little cutie
that you want to impress,
or if you just want a snack
to go along with your rom-com marathon,
well, we've got just the thing for you today
in today's food news.
(chewing sound)
(chuckles) That makes me laugh every time.
So Refinery29 has shared
the mother of all Valentine's gifts.
It's a meat bouquet Ross.
Oh, thank God.
Finally somebody invented it.
Look at that.
(laughter)
Well, and now you know flowers are nice dear
but it's been done.
I think this is a great idea.
Let me tell you.
You send me tulips great, I'm in.
But if you send me a bouquet of chicken fingers,
you can get it.
All right?
There's nothing I (mumbles).
The finger is the best part of the chicken,
everyone knows that.
(Drew laughs)
Right? I think this is a great idea.
And think about it,
for men if you're searching for your husband or something,
get him a meat bouquet.
He'll love it.
I think you all know what I'm thinking.
(laughter)
Well, anyway, Food52 is who recommended
that you go to Olympia Provisions
and get your loved one a meat bouquet today.
(Ross laughs)
(upbeat music)